well here's a really interesting story
so five days ago last Wednesday the FAA
ordered a ground stop on all air travel
in the U.S that meant that not a single
commercial or private aircraft was
allowed in the Skies over this country
that's very serious hard to overstate
the serious event actually the last the
only other time this country has imposed
a National Ground stop was after 9 11
the terror attacks 21 years ago so it's
a huge deal what happened why did the
government ground all the planes
so people asked but initially no one
seems to know P Buddha judge who runs
the transportation department oversees
the FAA went on TV to say he was not
quite sure
and then over the next several hours a
kind of story emerged the government
system that sends messages to Pilots
called No Tam had gone down
and then the emergency backup system had
also gone down now the FAA claimed it
first noticed this on Tuesday night when
the problem could not be fixed the
government issued a ground stop the next
morning
that's what people the judge said he
described the culprit here as quote a
damaged database file with no evidence
of a Cyber attack
so to repeat said people to judge there
was no evidence of a Cyber attack it was
just your garden variety software snafu
some contractor entered the wrong code
no big deal
that's what they said but it was not a
very convincing story if you thought
about it shutting down all commercial
air travel in this country even for a
morning is a very serious thing to do
U.S airlines haul close to three
quarters of a billion people every year
air travel is essential it's also
potentially dangerous so for a lot of
reasons it is imperative that our system
works perfectly
but one day our system just shut down
for no real reason is that what you're
telling us
yes explain Pete put a judge with a
straight face
now most people seem to think this was
fine we were not entirely convinced
and then the next day last Thursday we
noticed that virtually the same thing
happened in Canada
well that was very strange because the
U.S and Canada have separate Aviation
authorities they're different countries
and each country uses its own software
to Route their planes the systems are
not linked to each other
and yet 24 hours after our countries
know tem system went down Canada's no
temp system went down also
according to Canadian government its
system quote experienced an outage
really
what are the odds of that
and then we remembered that on New
Year's Day two weeks ago something
similar happened in the Philippines its
air traffic control system also went
down
for a time no aircraft were allowed in
Philippine airspace thousands of flights
over Asia had to be rerouted which is
expensive and dangerous potentially
now this was also they told us at the
time some sort of minor technical
problem that we should not worry about
calm down everything's fine
but is everything fun or is it possible
that somebody is hacking into Aviation
systems and holding various governments
around the world hostage until they pay
a ransom
well yes it's entirely possible in fact
for example in the summer of 2020 UCSF
medical school paid more than a million
dollars in Bitcoin and they paid it in
order to get access to their own
computers which had been frozen by
hackers they were held up for ransom
so what if the same people are similar
people just did something very much like
that to the FAA
and then to the government in Canada and
also the government of the Philippines
now if that were actually happening the
bite Administration would never tell us
in a million years they would lie about
it like they lie about everything else
they would have mayor Pete claim it was
a software glitch from a contractor
and they would lie to us because they
would not want us to know that they had
been so utterly Reckless and negligent
and distracted by Equity concerns that
they had allowed some foreign hostile
group to take control of our FAA
but the LIE could only cover so much
because there would be signs of it
almost all ransoms like this are paid in
Bitcoin so if the U.S government was
buying huge amounts of Bitcoin in order
to pay a ransom Bitcoin prices would
surge of course so the question is has
that happened
oh yes it has happened
since the Nationwide ground stop last
Thursday the price of Bitcoin has shot
up
about 20 percent
is that a coincidence
we asked Pete Buddha judge to come on
the show tonight to let us know
unfortunately he did not respond to our
request so we'll keep asking
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight